266 944.56
this is a down payment
on a very nice house
we're a very small place in new york
city hi muscle minhaj and i'm about to
go shopping online
let's do this
do i do a lot of online shopping i do
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's get some shoes
air jordan 11 concord 459 dollars
okay this is going to test my knowledge
of air jordan 11 concordes you guys did
not list
the year here i believe based on the
higher patent leather this is the 2018
edition
good job there we go what size are you
by the way i'm size 10 and a half 10 and
a half okay the price is actually 6 35
it went up to 635
i'm to be honest with you um
these are beautiful
these are beautiful um and
in this icy soul as a reminder that time
is finite our time on this earth is
finite
um and let the yellowing of these souls
remind all people that we have a limited
time on this planet
let's live life with our loved ones
and let's wear our jordans but never
ever crease your elevens nike banasi jdi
slide into the comfort in the
lightweight and sporty nike banasi jdi
slide wow nike slides are back
oh we're doing nike slides again i love
a good slide
i love a pair of jordan shorts with
slides like oof
socks are barefoot barefoot
barefoot air jordan won travis scott
fifty nine 2059.
you know what's crazy
but story time
i was gifted these
and i sold them on stockx no [ __ ]
megan repino
megan you gifted me these
and i straight up i straight up sold
them on stockx and i put them in an etf
in my daughter's name so thank you megan
cohan grandpa rally quartz sneaker 150
these aren't the hussa minhaj's though
these aren't the hussein minaj's though
they do have that back little red lip i
appreciate that
but i gotta let you guys know the hustle
minaj grand pro rally had that hairy
suede cohan is like from new hampshire
right uh do you know that without google
i had to look i'm gonna look it up
new hampshire baby your boys straight up
doing americana i love the collab that i
did these are actually pretty cool too i
could wear these like these are pretty
pretty versatile i could wear this with
this outfit right now i think just
from an investment standpoint let's grab
the travis scotts and let's flip them
again
let's hold them let's hotel for like two
years and let's flip them for three like
my daughter she's just like me she might
need some braces
travi
get my baby girl some braces let's do
this
oh my god let's talk about some records
seventeen dollars with the electrons
performance at wma do festival in 1985
was the first time the legendary kawali
singer had performed in front of a
mainly non-asian audience
damn
this is history bro to kawali music is
something that
when you're growing up
your parents play it in the car when
you're on the way to adava which is like
a family party when you're on the way to
the mosque or sunday school when i was a
kid
i was like turn this off as i've gotten
older
yo the pipes
the pipes on this guy legendary all time
i mean i would i would put him up there
as an icon up there with lata mangeshkar
let's keep going daft punk random access
memories 28 dollars and 73 cents
okay
we just have a daft punk album yeah
is it is it signed by daftbunk it's not
so it's just a daft punk album the album
is great yeah i could live without it
get lucky great track nazia hassan disco
dimani wow
this
cover
iconic
look at this like look at the vibes see
the way she's holding the mic and she's
doing this
dmx flesh with my flesh
blood on my blood fool 4095 classic
album rip dmx dmx was the third album
that i ever bought
so
this is up there and i remember being in
i think eighth grade when this when this
record came out people were like is it
humans blood
and then i think we all found out that
it was lamb or goat's blood which didn't
make it any
less terrifying such a great album and i
cannot believe
i cannot believe i listened to it listen
to it in the car with my parents i think
there's a line in it where he says i got
blood on my hand and there's no remorse
i got blood on my dick because i effed a
corpse
okay
that was playing in the car with both my
parents and my little sister this is
tough
but if i am getting vinyl and i'm
getting a record and it's the big case i
gotta go nazia hassan disco divani oh my
god
put that in the cart only for 16
steel
oh this is great i mean
you guys really did it gqu
you guys did it
let's take a look at cameo if you don't
know what cameo is
cameo is the service for twenty dollars
fifteen dollars or ten dollars
you can get vanilla ice to wish you a
happy birthday it's crazy
we've commoditized people's dignity in
like the most base way it's it's wild
lamarr owed him 200 no
y'all this is you guys are trying to
make me sad now floyd mayweather fifteen
thousand dollars
boy floyd but isn't floyd the one who's
like i i i'm i'm worth a billion dollars
i mean it literally is four seconds of
work floyd martha stewart impersonator
30
can i see how good she is i mean because
30 might be worth it for martha stewart
a person mike bibby 200
no mike
mike no
i don't i don't even need to see the
martha stewart in person impersonator
she was gonna be at the top of the list
i'm gonna do mike bibby for 200 but he
has to take his shirt off and flex
because mike bibby
bro mike baby got ripped mike bibby
looks like mike bibby swallowed another
mic baby
let's add that to the cart
let's get into fragrances
[Music]
a soft marrakesh intense
you de parfum a raw unorthodox fragrance
distinguished by woody spicy notes and
fresh florals a deep rich and alluring
homage to the city of the same name now
there's one thing about brown dudes who
do wear
um cologne
we go hard in the paint if we're going
out we're going to the club we're trying
to impress somebody at the mosque at
sunday school oh we're going hard suited
too this is really interesting
all genders explorers epicureans
let's play a new show this is called are
you a smart person without using google
in modern popular usage an epicurean is
a connoisseur of the arts of life and
the refinements of sensual pleasures
does that describe you
i think it describes gq.com
[Music]
yeah nice okay tom ford owed wood 650
rare exotic distinctive nah
hard pass let's keep doing this egyptian
musk fragrance oil 18.99 great price i
love how
like the top
of
the container of this thing it kind of
looks like a mosque that's really
beautiful and lovely i'm about to see a
minaret on the top it says the og sweet
uncle slash mosque fragrance you i
didn't even
i already told you this it's reading my
mind liz claiborne curve crush for men
this is 20 and 72 cents i was a
connoisseur of claiborne sport it was my
favorite in the eighth grade right now
there's a tie in my mind between
egyptian musk uncle fragrance oil or the
aesop marrakesh intense ooh de parfum
what i'm going to do is i'm going to go
with aesop marrakesh we're going to go
with the classic but upgrade it let's
add it
[Music]
i'm getting hungry oh yeah
let's look at some snacks
ooh healthy rams galapagos 26.99
amazon description cottage cheese
dumplings with cardamom with flavored
sugar syrup horrible horrible horrible
description here's how you describe
gulab jamuns it is a fried doughnut
drizzled
in syrup
amazon update it jalebi orange sweet
sticky and crispy swirls one pound 11.99
great i'm gonna be honest with you um
i'm more of a gulab jamming guy over
um
over jalebi crispy t-rusk nope overrated
my dad loves these i'm not a fan i'm not
a fan i hate these because these are in
the living room
and it's not like every daisy family has
a living room that you don't live in and
then you have a family room that you do
live in
any time there was a serious
conversation i'd have to go to the
living room and i would see these on
just like a silver tray and i'm like oh
[ __ ] dad's gonna say something not good
healthy rams kashmiri mixture nine
dollars and five cents is that a good
price
i'm gonna be honest i actually i
actually don't like i don't like these
my dad likes these i'm not i'm not a big
fan we're going with healthy robs gulab
jamun we just need to update the
description
about you boy
i moved on from ikea
let's get some furniture i don't even
this is how you know you're really doing
it big you can't even pronounce the
names i mean this is like something i'd
order at a restaurant so we got the
kacha pepe white silicone curb chair
senzafin for maritalia okay i don't know
what j
gaitano pesky sounds like a character in
the the disney plus film luca 11 200 for
something that looks like um you know
how when you when you take gum and you
stretch it out
yeah i'm gonna pass all right lc4 chaise
lounge by lick oh come on guys what are
we doing lick corbusier and charlotte
perrian you know i know i was the guy
who really harped on pronouncing
everybody's name correctly and i think
this is revenge 266 944.56
this is a down payment hard pass rose
quartz crystal hand carved bathtub by
baldi friends 1867 made in italy 1
million 449 472.73
for something that looks like it holds
soap is this like napoleon's bathtub
price 1 million 2000 euros the
assassin's credit is a single block
oh whoever did this was pure [ __ ]
evil oh you just walked into the amazon
rainforest you found a big-ass slab of
rose quartz crystal and you said hmm let
me take this back this is approximately
10 000 kilograms 10 000 quick
what do you know what that is in pounds
i don't know but i could google it
that's about
wow 22 046 pounds
if you've ever shipped anything on fedex
this is actually a steal if this is 22
000 pounds and it only is 1.5 million
shipping alone if i took this thing down
to a fedex kinkos they're at least
running me a good 3.5 mil
so i think i think right now i'm telling
you this right now i'm gonna buy this
just just for shipping prices alone um
herman miller air on chair
uh 1 190 all right these are super
popular in corporate america and i'm not
gonna lie to you guys i did buy one of
these
and and i'm gonna tell you this
right here right now exclusive overrated
they're really not that good i told you
what i'm gonna get this isn't about any
of these from a furniture standpoint i'm
gonna get the rose quartz crystal hand
carved bathtub
just
because of the shipping steel alone
it's so funny i read this slide i go
homies let's talk about our homies let's
take a look at some places that you
could live house in davis california
three million dollars
three million davis came up like this
this isn't even that nice of a house
look at this house it's kind of old an
opportunity like this rarely comes along
location location location you know
you're talking about davis california
hey people in the comments just tell me
what's going on in davis
is the frog tunnel still there is
taqueria guadalajara still there and by
the way is holmes junior high still
better than emerson junior high [ __ ]
emerson junior high ooh rihanna and
morocco
3 million property if you use five suite
seven bedroom twelve bathroom two living
room look at the views
look at the tile work they're ideally
located in the heart of the old dar the
bunch of area in the medina and close to
the popular souks this old mansion was
once owned by a rich spice merchant
i love that what year was this listing
italian retreat one million dollars look
at this dude we are getting ripped off
in davis beautiful rustic estate in the
green room the countryside of the
magnificent village of san panteleo the
property is located in a rural area
immersed in peace and tranquility i
already feel it okay let's go to the
last one nyc penthouse 25.95 million
dollars who put this up jared kushner
where are we at new york new york five
bedroom six bathroom 25 million dollars
now if it's gonna be 25 million dollars
we have to critique it i'm gonna be
honest with you the front of the
building doesn't look that amazing this
dining area not that big 25 million
dollars yeah i want alfred to live with
me 25 million dollars alfred should be
like mashed bruce you're home like i
need i need full-on alfred let's go off
the bat already house and davis we're
done i mean come on i like this is my
home this is my heart i filmed my first
comedy special in davis and you're gonna
list houses at three million dollars
you're gone um italian retreat one
million dollars good price i feel like
you're getting a lot it's really
beautiful it's in italy
um this spot in morocco
pretty incredible i think we go with
riyadh and morocco
add it to cart
gq thank you so much for taking me
shopping and thank you so much for
stealing someone else's credit card